Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Cecilia Bernabeni
Questo è un ponte.
Siamo nel 1952 a Mosca,
al centro di ricerca Kurchatov.
Un gruppo di ricercatori
sta testando una tecnologia
con lo scopo di ottenere
energia virtualmente illimitata, pulita,
senza scorie o sottoprodotti rilevanti.
Siamo in un'epoca in cui la guerra fredda
è in escalation piuttosto rapida:
il progetto, infatti,
è classificato come top secret.
Anche questo è un ponte,
ma di questo ne parliamo tra poco.
Ora torniamo agli anni '50:
i fisici russi, e poco dopo
anche quelli europei ed americani,
erano convinti
che sarebbe servito poco tempo,
e risorse relativamente limitate,
per ottenere una tecnologia
così profondamente rivoluzionaria.
Entrambi i blocchi,
sovietico e occidentale,
erano infatti reduci
da una prolifica serie di studi
sulla bomba H, la bomba a idrogeno,
ovvero una bomba termonucleare.
Il principio con cui funziona
la bomba a idrogeno
è in qualche modo simile
a quello che avviene all'interno del Sole:
due piccoli atomi, elettricamente carichi,
collidono, fondono i loro nuclei
e sprigionano una gigantesca
quantità di energia.
Quello che gli scienziati in questione
stanno cercando di ottenere
è lo stesso principio,
ma in un ambiente controllato.
Lo scopo quindi, ora, non è più
generare un'arma super-potente
bensì produrre energia
tramite la fusione nucleare,
o nuclear fusion.
Del resto, però,
costruire una stella sulla Terra
è piuttosto complicato,
ed emersero presto difficoltà
dal punto di vista ingegneristico,
delle scienze dei materiali,
della fisica teorica
e della fisica dei plasmi.
Un momento chiave,
che rappresentò una svolta
nella storia dello studio della fusione,
avviene nel 1958 a Ginevra,
alla conferenza soprannominata poi
"Atoms for Peace", "Atomi per la pace".
Uno degli obiettivi di questa conferenza
era quello di riunire i gruppi di ricerca
più rilevanti al mondo
e di presentare lo stato dell'arte
dello studio sulla fusione,
rompendo quindi
la classificazione top secret.
Questo è già un ponte meraviglioso.
Si giunse ad una quasi unanime conclusione
per cui il sistema migliore
per controllare
questa stella, questo Sole,
è attraverso un reattore
dalla forma toroidale,
un cosiddetto "Tokamak".
In due parole,
è una ciambella metallica
circondata da bobine
che generano campi magnetici
sufficientemente forti ed accurati
tali da poter controllare
questa stella, questo Sole,
confinarlo e stabilizzarlo
per un sufficiente periodo di tempo.
Ma quanto ci spaventano i cambiamenti?
Benissimo.
Se potessimo ottenere energia
dalla fusione oggi,
non cambierebbe assolutamente nulla
nella nostra vita di tutti i giorni:
semplicemente,
eviteremo di distruggere il pianeta
come sta avvenendo adesso.
Adesso.
Anche adesso.
Atoms for Peace è un punto di svolta
dopo il quale scienziati di tutto il mondo
cominciarono intense collaborazioni.
Ed in particolare,
intorno alla fine degli anni Ottanta
Europa, Stati Uniti, Russia e Cina
gettano le basi per una
collaborazione internazionale
con lo scopo di dimostrare
la fattibilità della fusione sulla Terra.
Il progetto si chiama "Iter" -
International Termonuclear
Experimental Reactor
ed è attualmente in fase di costruzione
a Cadarache, nel sud della Francia,
nella regione della Provenza.
Iter, che è l'opera tecnologica
più complessa mai realizzata dall'uomo,
sarà in grado di generare
un plasma di 100 milioni di gradi,
dieci volte più caldo del centro del Sole.
E a pochi metri
da questa relativamente piccola,
ma caldissima stella,
dell'elio liquido,
utilizzato per il raffreddamento
di alcune componenti,
avrà una temperatura di -270 gradi.
Quindi, nel giro di pochi metri,
il punto più caldo
e uno dei punti più freddi
dell'intero sistema solare
andranno a coesistere in Iter.
Nei decenni scorsi
sono, comunque, stati costruiti
altri reattori sperimentali
per lo studio della fusione.
Tra i più rilevanti vanno citati:
"JET", ad Oxford;
"ASDEX Upgrade" a Monaco;
"EAST" in Cina;
e "DIII-D" a San Diego,
alla General Atomics in California.
Attualmente io mi trovo in questa sede,
e ho principalmente due sensazioni
che viaggiano in parallelo dentro di me.
La prima è sicuramente gratitudine
per poter far parte di un progetto
così profondamente proiettato nel futuro.
La seconda è una sorta di responsabilità,
considerato che questo può, letteralmente,
modificare le sorti del nostro pianeta.
Questo, ovviamente,
vale per tutti i ricercatori
che come me condividono
questo viaggio fantastico.
Ma facciamo un passo indietro.
Da mediocre, talvolta pessimo,
studente alle scuole superiori,
come sono arrivato fino a qua?
Sicuramente,
un lavoro strepitoso e faticoso
da parte dei miei genitori
ha fatto la differenza.
Sicuramente, ho avuto
anche molta, molta fortuna
nel trovare professori
che mi stimolassero nel modo giusto.
Ma un elemento chiave,
che mi porto dentro ancora oggi,
è la cultura hip hop.
L'hip hop è un movimento culturale
che nasce negli Stati Uniti
agli inizi degli anni '70,
e che comprende al suo interno
la musica rap, i graffiti,
il dj-ing e la breakdance.
È sostanzialmente poesia in movimento:
un ponte unico, il cui motto è
"Pace, amore, unione e divertimento".
L'ho conosciuto con tutto ciò
che non era a scuola -
ma attenzione,
con questo non voglio assolutamente dire
che lo studio non apporti benefici;
anzi, specialmente ad oggi
lo studio è parte integrante
della mia quotidianità.
Bensì, che è coltivando
le proprie passioni
che si viene portati in luoghi
dove uno non avrebbe
mai pensato di ritrovarsi.
Un modo per andare oltre i propri limiti,
che siano questi imposti
da noi stessi o dagli altri.
È il sogno, l'obiettivo,
che ti permette di diventare
quello che non pensavi poter essere mai.
Ma quindi come ha influito un movimento,
apparentemente così distante,
nella mia vita e nel mio percorso
di lavoro e di studio?
Sicuramente, mi ha insegnato
il silenzio e l'ascolto.
Così come da ragazzini
passavamo interi pomeriggi
cercando di assimilare ogni singola parola
che ci veniva detta
dei ragazzi più grandi,
così oggi parte del mio lavoro
è studiare e ascoltare
opinioni di scienziati più anziani
che hanno fatto la storia
nel nostro campo.
Sicuramente mi ha insegnato
anche la pazienza,
perché così come prima
di poter partecipare ad eventi importanti
si passano anni di cosiddetta gavetta,
così oggi mi trovo coinvolto
in un progetto
che vedrà la luce dopo il 2080.
Esattamente.
Probabilmente, non potrò nemmeno
assisterci di persona.
Mi ha insegnato anche il rispetto
verso chi ne sa di più di me, certo;
ma anche verso chi ne sa di meno di me.
Perché tutti siamo stati principianti
almeno una volta, in tutto.
Sono l'attitudine al metodo
che questa cultura mi ha trasmesso,
che mi ha permesso di focalizzarmi
in un qualcosa di molto più grande di me.
In un'ottica collettiva,
e non individualista.
Tutto questo può essere racchiuso
in un vecchio detto afroamericano,
che ritengo oggi essere
più attuale che mai:
"Each one, teach one".
Anche questo è un ponte.
Grazie.
(Applausi)